[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les faits
mais pas lui
parmi toutes les pas de la saint-jean
celle de 1975 est entré dans la légende
gilles vigneault yvon deschamps et
louise forestier en tenait pour la
première fois jean du pays lors de méga
spectacle sur le mont royal
intitulé à la suggestion d'yvon
deschamps happy birthday et je lui ai
dit c'est le cachet du bas à peut-être
que oui on va l'appeler comme ça mais
mais on boit on va écrire une chanson
nouvelles chansons pour remplacer ap
liberté à nos fêtes chez nous au québec
ont cette année 1975 1 million 250 mille
personnes ont pris part aux festivités
organisées par lise payette une fête
mémorable qui a duré cinq jours
c'est vrai que ça a été extrêmement
important et émouvant
un des moments marquants de cette
semaine de célébration fut sans
contredit la prestation du ginette reno
et perpétrant un peu plus haut un peu
plus loin lors d'un hommage à jean
pierre ferland
[Musique]
ce
oui mais c'était pas moi qui devais la
chanter sur une est clos j'ai vu
monsieur imaginer j'ai pleuré un peu
devant un tel succès l'année suivante en
1976 les organisateurs ont présenté un
autre événement à grand déploiement sur
la montagne
le clou du spectacle était le concert
une fois cinq réunissant les 5 jean
baptiste charlebois vigneault léveillé
deschamps et ferland ont dit comme une
sorte de compétition
et puis à partir de ce moment là ne plus
jamais eu de compétition avec nous on
sait est dénoncée permet dans les deux
des amis pour toujours et elle me dit
[Musique]
et elle
après cette grande fête le 15 novembre
le parti québécois a accédé au pouvoir
et l'année suivante la saint jean
baptiste est devenue la fête nationale
du québec ici nabi alexandre chartier
radio canada montréal